welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
long-awaited trailer for spider-man no
way home a film now confirmed to blow
open the live-action spider-verse with
past franchise villains we never thought
we'd see in the mcu well some of us
thought we would and it's all thanks to
doctor strange being the cool dad to a
teen with cold feet cold because wong
left the sanctum freezer open to get
some hunk of hulk to burn and fudge and
yeah this trailer dropped on august 23rd
which is insanely the date won wanda
maximov and vision had hearted on their
calendar in wandavision coincidence not
here at new rockstars where our prayers
to mephisto are inevitably answered so
much to break down how these alt
universe villains got here how this fits
in with the other multiversal mcu titles
we've been talking about what other
spider-verse cameos could be happening
now so let's break this down frame by
frame for every detail you might have
missed okay the trailer opens with the
three first notes of the 60's animated
spider-man
spiderman
oh look at this peter and mj are on a
rooftop reading through news headlines
in the new york post reading peter
parker and his spider minions with an
image of peter's big yearbook photo head
on spider-man smaller body puppeting
marionettes with ned and it looks like
mj's face is on them oh don't do them
like that but then on the back side of
the newspaper looks like pray for new
york and then awesome detail here and
the graffiti in the background a nice
little nod to ditko for steve ditko
co-creator of spider-man with stanley
and the artist who inked much of the
trippy doctor strange artwork that is
inspiring this movie now spider-man far
from home ended with spider-man publicly
revealed as peter parker with this same
photo in a doctored video from mysterio
that made his death from a ricocheted
stark drone bullet that he actually
fired looked like peter ordering the
attack as well as the full attack on
london that video was released by
quentin beck's team after his death and
was broadcast by j jonah jameson host of
the dailybugle.net with jk simmons
reprising his role after playing it in a
different cinematic universe that was
the sam raimi trilogy and in those
movies the daily bugle was actually a
print newspaper as it seems to be in
sony's separate venom and carnage
universe but here in the mcu it's an
infowars inspired online outlet perhaps
why they're not reading a print version
here mj jokes about the gossip that
peter could hypnotize females before i
do a real thing in certain types of
funnel weaving spiders in which the
males produce pheromones to cause
females to enter a passive trance-like
state while that's not really one of
peter's powers he does in this movie ask
doctor strange to memory wipe all of
society and maybe guilt over mj's
gaslighting bit is one of many memories
that peter decides he does not want to
erase actually we see the direct
aftermath of the far from home
post-credit scene as peter and mj flee
the penn station corner to zip through
times square as j jonah jameson's voice
trumpets peter's identity the giant
screens project that same yearbook photo
with peter's face half-covered with the
spider-man mask an image that has
appeared on the cover of several
spider-man comics but memorably on
spider-man 366 in 1992 when red skull
and taskmaster tricked peter with the
return of his parents and peter finds
himself in custody cuffed to the table
confronted with this photo it looks like
of mysterio's body now peter's wearing
his nerdy physics is theoretical but the
fun is real shirt which she was also
wearing on the day tony stark dropped
him off after the civil war airport
battle now the guys questioning him
based on their patches are from the dodc
that's department of damage control the
same agency that cleans up the avengers
messes seen at the start of homecoming
looks like now they're also the feds who
step in whenever an avenger gets in
legal hot water and it's here where some
fans are still speculating that matt
murdock charlie cox from the netflix
daredevil could appear as peter's
defense attorney i will say it is
interesting how the frame cuts off the
face of the guy on the right with his
sleeves rolled up with arms as hairy as
charlie cox's arms warm enough to get
one through a sanctum winter i will say
he seems a bit aggressive with those
files to be peter's defense attorney but
i don't know maybe he's really mad that
peter let his cover get blown not really
sure though i will say this guy seems to
have a slightly different body shape
than charlie cox does the files peter
looks through could be all the
structural damage left behind in
spider-man's wake over the years like
the washington monument the staten
island ferry and now since they assumed
those stark drones were all controlled
by peter the whole time all the damage
we saw in far from home then a wide shot
shows midtown science and tech now in
the skyline you can make out the tower
that was once avengers tower which was
recently remodeled to be given an atrium
with a nearby sign on the ground level
reading we are so excited to show you
what comes next with the numbers 1 2 3
and
possibly a hint to the fantastic four
now the popular theory is that the
building could become reed richard's
baxter building and now that spider-man
director john watts is directing the
fantastic four film for marvel studios
as well i think that's a strong
possibility now on mj's walls are some
of her sketches including the same ones
she did of coach wilson knows hannibal
burris's character in homecoming when
she was drawing people in crisis peter
heads into school with ned and mj all
harassed by protesters behind them is
flash thompson now with blonde hair who
does this guy think he is natasha
romanov now some of the signs in the
distance are from people supportive of
peter that's nice to see looks like we
heart spider-man head or editor john
thinks we heart potatoes actually one
sign puts peter in devil horns with
devil in disguise okay don't don't don't
you dare say it no i don't think i will
okay i'll say it mavisto only because
the plot here does feel a bit similar to
the 2007 one more day storyline in which
peter asks doctor strange to save aunt
may's life but then ends up making a
deal with mephisto that involves the
world for getting that he's spider-man
that also requires him to split up with
mary jane now many readers were not huge
fans of that storyline for how it
retconned the character completely at
the time so much so that marvel later
had to kind of backpedal a lot of the
implications of it so i think while one
more day may influence the setup of this
movie the second and third acts look
like they're going in very different
directions peter and mj flee helicopters
that surround them atop a bridge
probably also part of the chase in the
minutes after mysterio outed him now
they're actually on the queensboro
bridge which runs alongside that
roosevelt island tramway the famous
setting of the showdown in the first sam
raimi film between spider-man green
goblin and mary jane and the people in
new york you mess with one of us you
mess with all of us peter faces a bunch
of gawkers from his fellow students at
midtown high on the screen looks like
the midtown morning news with host betty
brant live on the scene which i think
would be right outside this high school
now for her to be reporting on this
would be a bit of a conflict of interest
considering she and ned used to date now
as peter trudges through the high school
in the deep background are the science
and technology murals that include the
face of howard stark with the starks now
probably feeling further away from peter
as he drowns in public scrutiny and
since this is a shot of a bunch of young
extras naturally the dude the letterman
jacket on the right looks directly into
camera
then a shot of the camera rushing in on
aunt may and peter's living room they're
watching jay jonah jameson's daily bugle
show on the tv this could be the moment
authorities swarm their home to detain
them for questioning we actually see ned
and aunt may in an interrogation room
peter sees decorations showing plumpy
little doctor stranges with witch's hat
says halloween decorations giving him
the idea to ask doctor strange for help
now remember in far from home mr dell
thought the attacks were the doing of
witches what do you think it is you know
being a man of science
witches which we later saw him looking
up on his phone the events of one
division were set before far from home
suggesting that mr dell's fear could
have come from reports of the scarlet
witch in agatha harkness in nearby new
jersey and now peter is remembering if
those sorcerers could manipulate
memories so too could the sorcerer in
his corner so peter arrives at the
sanctum sanctorum finding the interior
frozen interesting and if you look at
the top of the stairs there doctor
strange is floating so cool now this is
the first time we have seen the sanctum
interior since the opening act of
avengers infinity war when hulk
transitioning back into banner blasted a
hole in the roof with the bifrost from
heimdall maybe that hole was left open
to let in a recent blizzard but i don't
know the stairs have been repaired with
a fresh layer frost on top of them but
also one room in the sanctum contains
doors to other geographic zones
including one with a cold climate of
heavy snowfall maybe one of those doors
was left open but the ice could be some
form of magic gone awry or a reflection
of the sanctum's mystical health but it
is worth noting that in addition to
doctor strange dustin upon the snap the
official screenplay for avengers end
game confirmed wong also dusted so
between may 2018 and october 2023 this
place was abandoned strange's cloak of
levitation clings to his shoulders over
a heavy winter jacket and underneath
that a hoodie for columbia university
that's dr strange's alma mater and
doctor strange has a mug showing a fox
reading oh for fox
also it is for fox's sake that this bub
now has a wider multiverse of x-men and
fantastic four to cross over into can we
get on that place then a shot where
peter pulls off a mask while wearing a
new black suit now designs for this
integrated suit leaked via merch earlier
this year it has gold mining described
as having mystic spider web effects
meaning this was designed for peter by
doctor strange maybe one that allows him
to toggle among past incarnations of a
suit and or use sorcerer magic to track
and capture entities from alternate
universes like by flipping web strings
made of magic now this facility is a
homeless shelter and you can see a
poster reading beast on the far right
there the homeless outreach organization
that peter works at in the comics and
played a big role in the ps4 game
actually the location with the which
decorations peter was in earlier also
could have been part of feast a league
set photo that went around recently
revealed a feast truck parked outside
the sanctum maybe peter volunteers at
feast as community service after getting
into trouble so peter asks strange to
make it so that mysterio never revealed
his identity and strange is like sure
okay despite a stern warning from wong
why does strange go along with this like
strange must know how dangerous this
spell is or how petty peter's wishes are
maybe peter's legal troubles are
becoming a security threat that strange
is concerned about or strange is
egotistical enough to assume that he can
address peter's wishes with the
precision of a surgeon's scalpel or
strange has some other motivation we
don't know about no
well maybe
i'm actually wondering if strange might
see a benefit in deliberately crossing
the streams of the multiverse to get
ahead of a chaotic crisis he knows is
coming in which he can harness some
interdimensional warriors or begin to
imprison some interdimensional threats
more on that strategy in a bit meanwhile
i'm not sure where wang is headed only
to guess that he could be off to face
abomination in a cage fight in chongqi
though if you look closely on the other
side of that portal you can kind of make
out a structure with pillars and a
trellis overhang we actually saw that
structure in the camera taj training
yard in doctor strange so that must be
where he is headed strange conducts the
spell in what looks like the sanctum
basement with the eye of agamotto once
again around his neck that's odd
considering the necklace's purpose
seemed to be the house of the time stone
which thanos has atomized and thanos
shattered that necklace on titan and
infinity war even though one brief shot
and end game included a continuity error
of strange wearing it perhaps the
necklace is a decorative piece that
strange reforged or an artifact that he
uses to store other mystical tokens of
use to him like a locket picture of wong
doctor strange floats in the same pose
that he made when looking forward at the
14605 future outcomes which makes sense
because this spell involves strange
accessing different timelines in the
multiverse now as part of the spell
strange pours a golden fluid in a bowl
which then strings out all pencil like
as a strand that morphs into a ring of
runes similar to the ones on leaked
promo art now that strand might be a
piece of peter's hair remember dr
strange similarly used a piece of thor's
hair to conjure a spell that located
odin and agatha used a piece of wanda's
hair to conjure a memory-based spell in
one division now uh hey if you like what
we do here at new rockstars or if you
like cool nerdy clothing and gear you
should be checking out
newrockstarsmerch.com on a regular basis
to see what new stuff just dropped our
partners at epic hero shop have put
together a full lineup of really cool
gear shirts stickers hoodies all kinds
of cool items to grab for yourself or to
give as a gift and completely blow your
nerdy friend's mind like if giving
someone a mobius on a jet ski t-shirt
doesn't say her friendship is real i
don't know what wood it was real to me
and they have just released brand new
items inspired by marvel's what if
including the newest edition of the
latest obsession line of t-shirts cosmic
witness now these are limited edition
shirts and won't be around for long and
whoa as this spider-man trailer is
dropping i am getting the text saying we
got some new spider-man no way home
inspired designs on the way they look
amazing there's actually an entire
lineup of merch inspired by the suicide
squad including some great stickers and
a king shark backpack and t-shirts and
kid sizes because nothing says back in
school like a character that keeps
graphically biting people's heads off
there's just plenty of other merch at
the shop inspired by loki black widow
wanda vision the mandalorian and all the
other nerdy properties that we love so
check it all out at
newrockstarsmerch.com you'll be helping
out our channel directly while also
earning some major nerd cred also notice
how this bowl is adorned with tiny
figures of animals looks like there's an
elephant and then a ram and then on the
left it could be a lion or a tiger also
kind of looks like an owl now the
elephant makes me think this is a relic
of indian or maybe african origin since
those are the places you can find
elephants in the wild there is the hindu
deity of ganesha who has an elephant
head and is known as the god of
beginnings or new enterprises but
elephants are also known for their
extensive memories which could also
connect with this being a memory-based
spell but it is tough if we're gonna do
any interpretation we gotta account for
all the animals now peter interferes
with the spell not just by physically
stepping into it but by verbally
expressing his change of heart as the
spell is underway i don't know maybe i
just have harry potter in the brain but
it looks like there's some sorting hat
rules going on here and the spell takes
peter potter's choice into account now
notice the spell forms four separate
rings which then tilt and chaotically
break reality around them opening up to
this nebulous void on the other side
which doesn't look too different from
the void of space of the sacred timeline
that surrounded the citadel at the end
of time in that loki finale we learned
that the sacred timeline is a ring that
circles back on itself so that could
clue us into the production design here
each ring could represent a separate
universe one for the mcu one for the
raimiverse one for the mark webb
universe maybe a fourth for sony's venom
carnage universe the components of the
spell colliding in breaking reality seem
to be the mechanics by which alternate
universe villains are now crossing over
into this movie the rings begin orbiting
independently of each other but then
knock into each other with each
collision perhaps causing a crossover of
a character or an entity from that
universe into this one now coming out of
loki in wanovision we're still not
entirely certain how much those events
affected the multiverse across all
marvel titles like this one because this
event seems to be separate from he who
remains sacred timeline breaking apart
however since loki established that time
from the vantage point of the citadel is
occurring all at once that breaking of
the timeline could be coinciding with
all kinds of seemingly coincidental
independent events like wanda with the
darkhold and now peter and strange in
this spell gone awry now at one point in
this multiverse imagery it flashes to
this textured tunnel this is actually
taken directly from dr strange's
multiverse montage in the 2016 film and
then we get an even quicker flash of
multicolored streams which match the
ones that shot out of strange's arms and
legs during that sequence now here the
frame cuts off whose limbs they're
streaming out of maybe one of the
spider-verse villains being pulled into
this reality or one of the alternate
peter parkers strange stops the spell
and the rings shrink down to hand-held
size but they continue to spin at these
chaotic angles to me this is also very
reminiscent of the machine and movie
contact title that only bring up because
it keeps weirdly coming up as a marvel
influence in titles like doctor strange
one division loki the machine in that
movie had four rings three of them
spinning all at different angles and
also opened an interdimensional portal
then we move on to some truly doctor
strange imagery the city of new york
bending into donut shapes i love this
strange says you tampered with the
stability of space-time the multiverse
is a concept about which we know
frighteningly little which is
interesting because of all marvel
characters doctor strange and peter
parker are really the only title mcu
heroes who have ever spoken of the
multiverse prior to loki at least
strange experienced a trip through the
multiverse thanks to the ancient one and
far from home when peter met mysterio he
proved that he had thought quite a bit
about the multiverse i'm sorry you're
saying there's a multiverse because i
thought that was just theoretical i mean
that completely changes how we
understand the initial singularity again
i just think strange knows a lot more
about the multiverse and he might be
using peter to get what he wants from it
now the city appears to be sinking at
the exact part of new york city where
the sanctum sanctorum is located 1778
bleaker street that would be not that
far from washington square park as
you're overlooking the river toward new
jersey now in this shot peter looks at
his hand as if his web shooters are not
functioning maybe he's out of webbing or
maybe strange's spell won't let him use
them but in either case it does recall
the moment in sam raimi's spider-man 2
when peter's stress caused him to run
out of organic webbing mid-swing that's
right let us not forget that the rainy
trilogy did not use classic spider-man
web shooter devices but made peter's
webbing spew out of his wrist skin i
can't wait to see that conversation
between tom and toby and cue my favorite
fat cut
what's going on in there
next this shot of a dust cloud swirling
among some news vans including a daily
bugle van and then a bolt of lightning
strikes through it we might be seeing
two spider-verse villains here electro
and sandman jamie foxx who played
electro in the mark webb andrew garfield
amazing spider-man 2 in 2014 was the
first past villain confirmed for this
movie until now tom satan church sandman
from raimi's spider-man 3 in 2007 has
only been rumored then strange faces
spider-man on this speeding train
through what looks like the freaking
grand canyon aside from the mountainous
setting as evoked toby maguire's
spider-man famous duel with doc ock in
the 2004 film strange duplicates the
train car into eight of them similar to
his images of icon spell that he used
against thanos in infinity war the train
track also splits into duplicates a
fitting metaphor for the way the marvel
timeline is branching off into alternate
courses when nexus events rupture the
sacred timeline during this strange
blames peter for trying to live two
different lives as what caused the spell
to misfire in addition to the one more
day storyline this also reminds us again
of the 2004 film when peter gave up his
second life and paid a price for it if
you think about in the mcu peter's
really the only prominent superhero
who's trying to hold on to his anonymity
when everyone else just kind of lives
very public lives and again i think it's
super odd that strange is antagonizing
peter here when stranger's the one who
agreed to do the spell in the first
place strange pushes peter's astral
projected soul from his spider-man body
similar to how the ancient one pushed
bruce banner's astral self from his hulk
body now as strange does this the
surrounding world freezes which they
cleverly show with a ton of autumn
leaves frozen in place as well as the
woman walking the dogs actually reminds
me of that first raimi movie where he
used the background details like the fly
and the spitball to convey peter's
spidey sense now peter is holding an
interesting looking cube and you'll
notice it has the seal of vashanti on
the sides what is this i am wondering if
this could be an artifact from dr
strange's collection a kind of pocket
prison that strange uses to contain the
alt universe villains that he is trying
to corral i guess kind of like a
ghostbusters trap this seems to be the
macguffin football that peter and
strange wrestle over possession of
strange wants it for his reasons maybe
peter wants it to release these captives
back to their homes thus no way home
then peter wears his iron spider armor
on an overpass the setting of a major
set piece we'll talk more of later now
he wore that suit only in the beginning
of far from home and in a delayed scene
when he took down the man freddie crime
family other than that he left it
charging in his bedroom swat police
closed in on a burning building based on
happy hogan's reaction i'm wondering if
this could be that safe house that peter
mj and ned were using based on those
early production photos that were
released and now one of peter's enemies
could have found it and bombed it out
maybe with some pumpkin bombs then a
very quick shot that i think explains a
lot of what is going on peter is in a
dark murky place and then suddenly the
lizard jumps out at him hitting a
transparent barrier so remember reese
iphones played the lizard in the 2012
andrew garfield amazing spider-man
reboot i think this is the interior of
that pocket prison artifact that peter
and strange have been fighting over and
that strange is collecting all these
eclectic sinister six villains like
pokemon and pokeballs because he knows
the multiverse is about to erupt and he
wants to neutralize all potential
threats before that happens look folks
of this pokeball ghostbuster trap
sounds too crazy i will direct
you to literally any other shot in this
trailer this movie is gonna be weird
then spider-man takes cover from a bolt
of electricity perhaps coming from
electro though i can't tell if the bolt
is kicking up dirt or if sandman is
forming a shield to ground the current
and protect peter we return to that
overpass where this woman in her car is
just staring at peter unblinking we
might be seeing time slow down again and
peter's spidey senses tingling as he
senses the threat then the money shot of
this trailer a green goblin punking
grenade is tossed up from the collapsed
edge of the overpass and we hear the
iconic laugh of willem dafoe as norman
osborne
this was the rumored appearance i was
most excited about after this guy died
in the first film in 2002 defoes osborne
continued to haunt the trilogy through
the mirror of his son harry and he stole
every scene he was in now if we go by
alfred molina's quote defoe osborne
might have been brought into this
reality from the moment of his death my
favorite death from the rainy trilogy
god speaks spider-man
oh
don't tell harry
but instead strange's spell could have
yanked osborne out of the way of that
glider either way osborne and octavius
think they're in a weird kind of heaven
now however we also hear green goblin's
glider in the cloud of dust from which
doc ox mechanical arms claw at us
also a glimmer of green light and then
as reported last december alfred molina
as dr otto octavius greets us so excited
to see this guy again now it looks like
a bit of de-aging might have been done
to molina's face as he said was gonna be
the case meaning we can also probably
trust his other statements from that
interview he's wearing a turtleneck and
tinted sunglasses instead of the blacked
out frames in the low v plus high collar
meanwhile peter suits up with the
nanotech of his iron spider armor now
coating him now doc ock is climbing up
on the george washington bridge which
makes the waters beneath him the hudson
this is the river that ock drowned in in
the 2004 film the moment in the river
that alfred molina said this movie would
pick up with his character from now it's
interesting how doc greets tom holland
spider-man with a friendly hi peter
since his peter parker was toby maguire
this would suggest that doc ock is more
of an expert on the multiverse logic by
which he was transported to this reality
and he might be able to conclude that
any version of spider-man is peter
parker even if this peter looks
different or in this moment doc ock
might simply be greedy not tom holland
peter but the peter from his universe
that he would recognize the one played
by toby mcguire or that doc ock and the
others being brought here was the result
of peter's individual wish and that his
version of octavius has more of a
connection with this peter that's really
why i don't think peter's relationship
with these villains is gonna be so
necessarily antagonistic he might be
trying to help them go home restoring
the multiverse into separate universes
and deciding he can live one life a life
with the consequences of his actions now
what about all those other cameos that
have been speculated the alternate peter
parkers from those realities toby
maguire andrew garfield or charlie cox
as matt murdock again there have been
numerous unconfirmed reports tom holland
and andrew garfield both denied it many
fans did not believe them but i will say
it certainly seems more possible now if
the villains from these universes can
get transported into the mcu why not the
heroes now i would be surprised if sony
revealed those in a trailer and while i
would love to see a quick cameo of toby
or andrew through a portal or something
i'm also totally okay with this being
tom holland's movie and the mere
prospect of alfred molina and willem
dafoe showing up has me thrilled beyond
imagination for this film we are in the
end game now my friends between now and
december new rockstars is going to be
speculating like crazy about this film
and we got a lot more videos coming your
way and you can support new rockstars by
checking out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching
[Music]
you